osmani das ist ein albanischer klaren
sie sehen sich als ganz normale
kaufmannsfamilie die zwar auf dem kiez
im großen stil immobilien investiert hat
aber ansonsten mit dem rotlicht-milieu
rein gar nichts zu tun habe doch seitdem
die mitglieder auf wundersame weise ihr
vermögen vermehrten sind ihn auch
ermittler auf den fersen jetzt endlich
ein erfolg der clan-chef wurde
festgenommen der verdacht kokain handel
zweiter märz 2022 palma de mallorca der
mann der hier in handschellen ins
gerichtsgebäude gebracht wird ist
bashkim osmani den 55 jährigen hamburger
wird vorgeworfen mafia pate und boss
eines kokain rings zu sein
zwei wochen zuvor in sechs europäischen
ländern hebeln über 600 beamte ein
internationales netzwerk an kokain
händlern aus osmani und 45 weitere
personen werden verhaftet ermittler
beschlagnahmten kunstwerke schmuck
bargeld luxusautos und bashkim osmani es
1000 quadratmeter villa in kampe
mallorca mein geld ist das ergebnis
harter arbeit und intelligenter
investitionen das sagt bashkim osmani
dem ermittler von guardia civil und
internationalen partnern
kokainhandel im ganz großen stil
vorwerfen hier hinter mir im hafen von
puerto portals
betrieb er über jahre lang seien sehr
gut laufen das restaurant re ziehen doch
das was in den büchern stand und was man
theoretisch mit diesem restaurant
umsetzen konnte passt er nie zusammen
unter anderem zum verhängnis wurde
bashkim osmani nach angaben der
ermittler ein abgehörtes gespräch seines
finanzdirektors des raids es in dem er
sich beklagte gegenüber einem
steuerberater zitat es ist schwer der
buchhalter der mafia zu sein wir haben
uns auf die spuren dieses mafia
imperiums hier auf mallorca begeben und
haben orte besucht die eine wichtige
schlüsselrolle im teil dieser
ermittlungen gespielt haben
der fall aus mali beginnt bereits im
dezember 2016 damals wird ein
drogenkurier im raum lübeck festgenommen
durch ihn gelangen große mengen
rauschgift von albanien nach deutschland
verdeckte ermittler observieren
daraufhin eine gruppe verdächtiger in
norddeutschland unter ihnen soll sich
auch die hamburger rotlicht größe hat
rihanna befunden haben spitzname albaner
toni die fahnder bekommen wind von einer
zahlung an südamerikanische
drogenkartelle albaner toni soll diese
veranlasst haben durch ihnen kommen die
ermittler schließlich bashkim osmani auf
die spur
das restaurant rizzi auf mallorca gehört
der familie aus mali hier trafen sich
bashkim osmani albaner toni und andere
komplizen regelmäßig und wickelten ihre
geschäfte ab dabei immer im schlepptau
verdeckte ermittler die fleißig mit
hören und fotografieren
noch heute wird das restaurant von der
familie aus mali betrieben bild reporter
jan henrik dobers besuchst du dass rizzi
und bat um ein gespräch mit dem
geschäftsführer wir würden gerne mit dem
neuen geschäftsführer sprechen ich weiß
dass der alte im gefängnis ist aber es
wäre super wenn wir mit dem neuen chef
oder der neuen chefin sprechen können
auf nachfragen möchte man sich uns
gegenüber aber nicht äußern
aber die polizei auf mallorca spricht
wir treffen den einsatzleiter der
operation kapitän juan carlos g von der
guardia civil in palma de mallorca in
den letzten zwei jahren war er chef
ermittler im fall aus mali da er immer
noch verdeckt ermittelt möchte er
unerkannt bleiben juan carlos lebte
osmani ein luxusleben auf mallorca
villen autos jachten woher das ganze
geld kann bleibt fraglich
dass es auf legale weise erwirtschaftet
wurde ist unwahrscheinlich
die haben keine indizien dazu gefunden
dass das viele geld was er hatte legal
war er verwaltete eine menge geld aber
es gab keine legale wege wie dieses geld
in seine hände gekommen ist das hat uns
zu dem entschluss gebracht dass er
tatsächlich geld gewaschen hat
wir fahren in das idyllische städtchen
kannte mal im südwesten mallorcas bis
februar wohnte bashkim osmani hier mit
ehefrau und schwiegervater in seiner
luxusvilla laut guardia civil ist das
mittlerweile beschlagnahmte anwesenden
15 millionen euro wert wir versuchen mit
frau aus mali zu sprechen
würden wir uns einmal ganz kurz
doch auch hier möchte man nicht mit uns
sprechen die beschlagnahmte villa wird
momentan weiterhin bewohnt und es ist
nur eine frage der zeit bis sie verkauft
wird
doktor heime kampala ist bashkim osmani
es rechtsanwalt er vertritt den
55-jährigen seit februar diesen jahres
von der unschuld seines mandanten ist er
überzeugt
ich habe schon von anfang an gesagt dass
es keinerlei beweise gegen meinen
mandanten gibt und deswegen arbeiten wir
auch so hart an seiner freilassung wir
glauben man will aus ihm den teufel
machen ich hoffe dass diese
untersuchungshaft für meinen klienten
bald ein ende hat ich bin zuversichtlich
dass dieser albtraum bald zu ende ist
bis dahin sitzt das team osmani
weiterhin im gefängnis von palma de
mallorca in der jva in der über 1000
insassen untergebracht sind gibt es
nicht annähernd den luxus den osmani
bislang genoss